[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants j'espère que vous
avez été sage aujourd'hui oui pas trop
tu ressors alors je propose que nous
fassions tous ensemble un beau concert
oui aux consorts potro
oui un vrai concert nous jouerons chacun
d'un instrument de musique différents
jeux peugeot but we descend vite mon
gros nounours
dès que vous êtes prêts nous commençons
propos bonsoir le genre on a appris que
la bbc et on va la jouer toute la saison
au ceux qui sont restés
[Musique]
vous êtes près les musiciens m
rebond les gens en bravo bravo à la plus
tôt quand un look aux lazzis loeb
musicale
si je vous accompagne
[Musique]
le music
le music bénigne ou coniques grand
musicien paul denis hurley
[Musique]
faites vous pour panis-nicolas peau nue
pimprenelle tort bien bonne nuit petit
nicolas bonne nuit petit pas pr neil
bonne nuit tous les enfants allez vite
vous coucher et embrasser bien fort vos
parents
alors en route grands virtuoses bon ami
est au bourg
[Musique]